figured out how I can enjoy new Trek
this is a bit of a revelation for me
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
with your Channel
[Music]
so I have a bit of a problem with some
elements of a new Trek because I'm
afraid Canon actually matters to me I'm
one of those annoying people that
doesn't really like prequels because
they tend to pee on camera I was
frustrated by the JJ Abram Star Treks
because
you know they changed so much about what
I love about Star Trek even though I
then learned to love those movies I just
don't think of them as track
so how do I enjoy new track because
Unfortunately they do change Canon quite
a lot the first season definitely of
discovery changed it's Canon quite a lot
the second season did a little bit and
strange new worlds is starting to step
on the toes of Canon as well
and it irritates me even in Picard they
sort of change things or make silly
mistakes things that I know aren't right
and I get frustrated and you guys know I
get frustrated because I then do videos
about it so how do we enjoy new Trek
when they keep doing things like
Spock gets a sister we knew nothing
about or now Spock started a
relationship with nurse Chapel something
that we knew nothing about or they start
a war with somebody that we knew nothing
about or something else well
I think I figured it out
it's not really Star Trek now before you
get annoyed at me
I'm gonna sort of refine that a little
bit it's obviously still Star Trek and
if you love the new track
all power to you I I I'm not telling you
whether you're right or wrong if you
hate Star Trek I'm not telling you
you're right or wrong this is my
personal opinion how do I
frame or think about Star Trek so I can
actually just enjoy it and stop getting
wound up by it
[Music]
I take it back you're not a genius I'm
going to think of it as Star Trek 2.0
it's not quite the same as Star Trek
that we know and love as in Voyager Deep
Space Nine and most importantly the Next
Generation
she's ready
engage I'm going to try to remember that
this is a completely new iteration of
Star Trek that these are new actors in
those roles and that Spock is a little
bit different to the Spock we know
because that actor you know wants to
maybe put a little bit of himself into
it and I don't blame him I kind of
understand it
Kirk is going to be a little bit
different Pike is going to be a little
bit different
so maybe we shouldn't stress it so I
with strange new worlds I have to admit
I'm struggling to get into the series
we've just had the fifth episode and
actually I enjoyed it I thought it was a
really good episode
it was funny it was quite clever it you
know showed us different aspects of her
character in lots of ways it was the
essence of Star Trek you know a
transporter accident it was that kind of
thing that is Iconic sort of Star Trek
storylines
I know it wasn't a transporter accident
before you get into the comments but
it's that sort of thing
and I really think Strange New Orleans
is trying to sort of replicate some of
those original series episodes that we
had before it's trying to feel like
Roddenberry Star Trek and that's not a
bad thing either
but as I said they keep messing with
Canada now the church chapel thing I
actually had somebody email me saying
like that's it now I've had enough of
this they've pissed around Canon again
since when this book ever have a
relationship with nurse Chapel
I don't actually remember anything in
Star Trek that says he didn't
so if they break up at some point
during strange new worlds then you know
maybe Canon isn't messed with now there
is a theory going around that actually
strange new Wheels is a different
timeline it's actually not the same
timeline as the original series
um you could argue that maybe hey maybe
something happened in Enterprise during
the temporal Cold War and all of new
Trek is a slightly different timeline
I hate that sort of thing it winds me up
but you could argue that
You could argue this is perhaps a Kelvin
timeline
now there are other things about strange
thing will today irritate me slightly
Pike has not been in it enough now 18
they actually use opportunity to leave
basically his wife has recently had a
new child and that's why he's not been
in the early episodes of strange new
worlds as much as he normally would be
to that I would say the producers need
their heads examining they knew when
that baby was due it wasn't a surprise
so they really should have adjusted the
um filming schedule to allow Pike to be
in it as normal
not just have episodes where he's not in
it now I know we got to see The Wider
Enterprise crew and stuff and they get
to stand forwards and maybe that's
something that's their thinking and we
don't want this to be the puncture but
Anderson Mount is the most popular I
think character on there and he really
is the captain of the ship he has to be
in every episode the captain is if I
thought
so that has frustrated me
they've changed the Enterprise which
frustrates me those crew quarters are
freaking massive and to be honest so are
the shuttles they're enormous
that is a little irritating
so again these are the things that they
keep changing
but if you don't think of it
again as original Star Trek if you think
of it as Star Trek 2.0 with a slightly
different attitude from the creators
then I think you can actually enjoy new
track a little bit more without getting
quite as frustrated as I have been at
the most damning thing of all
I think I can live with it
[Music]
and if I had to do it all over again
I would
so that's what I'm going to do in future
it's not Star Trek not really it's Star
Trek 2.0 there are going to be
differences and that's okay Canon is
going to be stepped on a little bit to
tell the story but let's be honest Star
Trek has always done that and it's okay
Star Trek 2.0 is beautifully made
it's quite well written as far as
strange new walls goes yeah okay they
make mistakes
Picard season 3 was full of them but it
was still brilliant
so I'm going to change my thinking
Star Trek 2.0
maybe I can enjoy it a bit more without
my heart getting a bit too rapid
but guys tell me what you think into the
comments do you maybe think that all
right All Star Trek is great Star Trek
and we shouldn't worry about that anyway
let's just enjoy the stories or do you
actually think Canon really does matter
and if something is on film things like
the romulo or the Klingon wall blah blah
these things are actually set out in
history of Star Trek then they really
shouldn't be messing with them really
the creators should know enough just to
right in that and actually
do you think that we didn't need strange
new worlds as a show if that show was
based aboard the Endeavor with Captain
poke and you know first Commander
I don't know Steven and a different list
of characters that I would have actually
made a more interesting show because
they wouldn't have been constrained by
what we know is coming later in the
original series it's the same argument
that I had for Enterprise
that show should have been called
something like the Melbourne or anything
the creators are absolutely obsessed
with having the Enterprise Kirk Spock
and so on they don't need to again the
comments are telling me if you agree
with me that actually that obsession is
kind of ruined in Star Trek I wish
they'd get away from it to Big Universe
people
get the comments tell me exactly what
you're thinking if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
you can also go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you get to see
most of our new videos first and for
small contribution each month you get to
see them without the adverts as always
please stay safe guys enjoy Star Trek
2.0 and I'll see you next time
[Applause]
[Music]